signori siamo tornati sui nuovi episodi
scrivo punto io perché sto gioco merita
la vita e la prima vedere se c'è
qualcosa di decente
colline colline collina collina oppure
macchina macchina aspetta vaio mario
mario maiolo ha indovinato te stesso
porca vacca ti droghi bene è vero che
partono chat molto tranquille ok se ti a
dondolo eroina thing is here
che figata quando la gente scrive la
parola per far indovinare più cose prova
bene grazie mille ho fatto un sacco di
punti lo scalando la classifica anche se
non vale perché avete iniziato due ore
fa però arrivato sesso in mezzo a
rebecca e michael grazie ma ricordiamo
di nuovo dai facciamo le cose serie
stavolta parti sergente file e robe
fatte bene allora faccio io prete prezzo
armadillo prezzo wrestler
ok faccio io faccio io guarda qua come
cosa ti cucino cosa ti cucino per bene a
[Musica]
questo è questa la faccia piatta
fortissimo aspetta è difficile fare ring
e ragazzi è difficile ma che
abbracciarsi queste sta menando questi
se stanno menando noi questo è un prete
orco demonio parte che non lo vedi che
un ring si sharing fatto meglio di così
è veramente difficile wrestling sì però
è il tipo ma che acchiapparella ma chi è
che ha preso povera rebecca cotti
infantile poverina dai bravi solo mario
è dominato fate cagare maschile della
prima di rebecca rischiare presto opera
rebecca che si sta roba qua ragazzi
padre padre pedro ma io non ho libri
ragazzi vi giuro non lo so
giuro non ho idea ha indovinato anche
michael cia 0 anni come ho fatto
l'intervento
a madre io ho scritto padre cioè io ho
scritto padre poi ho indovinato tutti
perché non è padre sarà madre e io sono
stupido sono stupida demente un demente
ragazze non so come sia possibile dai
figlio padre cristo tavolo bene ciao
sala fini è dominato come a porta che
film come faccio mai dai michael dai
michael dai michael e porta michael dai
michael bay che porta ora come confuso
michael poverino che porta michael porta
a porta e porta dai michael che porta e
porta e porta poi io facevo stupito che
prima non indovinato madre perché non
c'è bisogno che era colori parte va
ricordata malissimo poi ha dribblato il
pomello per non colora il pomello dai
michael allora urlano olio excalibur
mammamia scappare excalibur
questa è difficile questa e la spada e
poi c'è un tizio che tenta di prenderla
molto bene
no troppo troppo se non la indovinate
fate cagare
c'è veramente facile ma cosa terremoto
michael michael non te ne leggeva
lamentele leggeva ma le storie
maledizione ma come terremoto porco
demonio kama kama kama kama come
possibile come terremoto ma come mago
michael e maicon ormai col mercato
perché michael si impegna lo so che si
impegna non peccato trampolino madonna
senza piscina no impiccato a lampione
nomina
peccato perché maicon l'ha fatto molto
bene porca vacca s'è impegnato michael
impiccato un arrivato due ore dopo
checkpoint scritto check poi voglio
morire adesso prezzi altre frecce palamà
dai arciere norci dovevo scrivere nord
ar
sì è vero che non è quello al chelsea
scolari non scrivo i ball
balestra tutto qua non era difficile
badessa in realtà lei michael è riuscito
a michael di michael e la valletta di un
giocatore che peccato
fioretti siamo rimasti in pochi ma buoni
dai ti direi patata
no è una persona veramente felice è il
suv un suv subacqueo alle un ladro ladro
rapinatore rapinatore lo scritto prima
sacco e un rapinatore un bassotto è un
sacco di soldi ho capito è un ladro
ladrone ladroni ah no è la pistola
pistola arma ho capito è un po è un
comunista è un ormai gangster nessuno
che ha indovinato il match su uno che è
indovinato james neanche io ci ho 34
anni codice morse
mario maria mario mario mario dai torna
a casa mario ma ritorno a casa per
cortesia
in realtà aveva ragione mario questo nè
codice morse e il codice breil breil
come si dice ora ho avuto l'accortezza
di capire che il tipo non avrebbe mais
che alessia non sa che cosa sia il brand
e quindi ho detto lei saprà morse quindi
mettere i puntini per il morso dopo
passo avanti a tutti
complimenti chiuso vuoto cinema vulcano
se volgiamo bellissimo ci aveva fatto
onore al maestro domenico e nel
frattempo eccolo tutti ha indovinato il
vulcano very good
sono ancora secondo mario 85 punti siamo
alla resa finale nei conti se indovino
questa qua lo per mare e ciccio osso
questa era veramente semplice però
teoricamente dovrebbe sorpassare mario
di punti e lo star passa in finale non
so cosa in finale ce la fa ce la fa
vostro passato mario alla fine mario tra
si giocata molto bene bravi sia piaciuto
non mi piace è piaciuta campanellina
fatica capire se volete altri video del
genere anche se so che la risposta è sì
e noi come sempre ci vediamo anche
seguito dai ragazzi
[Musica]